what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of content just like this and
hit the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video
this is my statistics tutorial series
where I give you all the applied
statistics knowledge that you need to
conquer the data science world so if you
haven't yet seen my videos on the
hypothesis testing framework as well as
on p-values and P hacking I strongly
recommend watching those videos before
this one and I'll have links to both of
those in the description and cards up
above in those videos I went through the
steps that you'll take in any type of
hypothesis testing problem as well as
one of the most important definitions in
the whole field of statistics and that's
the p-value specifically I went through
what a p-value is and what it is not now
I'm gonna walk you through some more of
the most important concepts in
statistics and those are type 1 error
type 2 error statistical power and the
lesser known type 3 err here's the
definitions the probability we make a
type 1 error is the probability we
reject H naught if H naught is actually
true and that probability is represented
by the symbol alpha the probability we
make a type 2 error is the probability
we fail to reject H naught when H naught
is actually false that's represented by
beta then statistical power which is
related is the probability we correctly
reject H naught when H naught is false
and that's represented by 1 minus beta
and naturally I have to share this
hilarious image that gets floated around
a lot when people talk about these
definitions so I think the working
assumption that the overwhelming
majority of people have is that they're
not pregnant if they have reason to
doubt that they'll go take a test and
that test will give either a positive or
a negative result so just think of not
being pregnant as our null hypothesis
here on the left side here we have the
type 1 error of telling a man that
they're pregnant that obviously can't
happen
on the right side we have the type 2
error where a doctor or a test fails to
classify somebody as pregnant when they
very clearly and obviously are now I
think one of the hardest things for most
people who are just getting into
statistics for the first time is
remembering these definitions and
keeping the difference between them
straights and for a lot of people using
a table like this is pretty helpful but
personally when I was learning these for
the first time I found it helpful to
just think about these as conditional
probabilities so if you just remember
that H not being true goes with type 1
error we'll just think about it if H
naught is true the only way we can make
it error is to reject H naught likewise
with type 2 error that goes with H
naught being false the only way we can
make an error there is if we fail to
reject H naught so if I just remembered
that H naught being true went with type
1 error that way I could figure out all
the pieces of both type 1 error and type
2 error so when I was learning this the
first time that's what worked for me but
to each their own the other thing you
have to remember is that the probability
of type 1 error is represented by alpha
the probability of type 2 error is
represented by beta and as alpha
increases beta decreases and vice versa
then naturally if you have beta
decreasing 1 minus beta that is the
statistical power is going to increase
and then 1 minus alpha is the confidence
level that's associated with a
confidence interval which is also
something that can be used to reject or
fail to reject a null hypothesis now
let's dive a little bit more into the
trade-off between the risks of type 1
error and type 2 error you see you
actually set the type 1 error rate at
the beginning because that's the same
thing as the significance level so you
have to think about how bad is a type 1
error for context let's just suppose
you're working in a clinical trial
environment and you have a null
hypothesis that there's no difference
between some new drug and a placebo if
you reject that null hypothesis you are
claiming you have ever
that that new drug performs differently
than the placebo does considering
there's probably some extremely serious
implications for saying something like
that saying that we've discovered a new
drug but then it turns out later that
we're wrong it's probably best to have
as low of a type-1 error rate as
possible and it's usually the case that
type 1 errors are worse than type 2
errors but that's far from a universal
rule here's the thing if we set a higher
significance level you can kind of just
think of it as making it easier for
ourselves to reject the null hypothesis
and that's true whether the null is true
or if it's false so if we have a higher
significance level that's the same thing
as saying we have a higher type one
error rate but we also have higher
statistical power but the flip side of
that is true to that is if you have a
lower significance level you need a
higher standard of evidence in order to
reject the null hypothesis so the chance
you reject it even when it's false and
you should reject it becomes lower as
well that is you have lower statistical
power now let's talk a little bit more
about power because that concept is a
little tricky in and of itself and
almost always when people do power
calculations they will do them using
some kind of software to understand
power let's start by understanding it's
related to three other quantities that's
significance level for the reasons I
described earlier sample size and what's
known as effect size for effect size the
most common metric for that is what's
called Cohen's D which is just a
difference in means divided by a common
or pooled standard deviation you can
calculate power using R or Python and
there's tons of free calculators out
there that you can google but the most
important thing is to understand the
relationships power goes up as you
increase the significance level it goes
up as you increase the sample size and
it goes up as you increase the effect
size and you won't necessarily always
see power of a test being reported but
in any kind of research as well as in
clinical trial or manufacturing contexts
providing the power of the test is just
really good really thorough science and
it's just a good practice to get in the
habit of
reporting it now there are some other
types of errors although they're much
more rarely discussed and those are type
three and even type four errors there's
actually a few different definitions
that get floated around for the type 3
error one common one is finding the
right answer to the wrong question but a
much more specific and frequent
definition of the type 3 error is
rejecting the null hypothesis for the
wrong reason so let's give an example
let's go back to my example from my
previous videos where we were testing a
null hypothesis that the average number
of hours Americans use their phones is
3.5 hours let's suppose also we had an
alternative hypothesis that that true
mean was greater than 3.5 hours now
let's just suppose for a second the true
mean was actually 3.2 hours but we took
our sample it was of size 50 and we got
a sample mean of 4 hours and a standard
deviation of 1 point 2 hours we would
end up rejecting the null hypothesis and
concluding people actually use their
phones on average for more than 3.5
hours a day when the reality is the
exact opposite they use their phones for
less than 3.5 hours per day on average
but because maybe we didn't conduct our
sample in a great way we oversample
people who use their phones a lot and we
just so happened to set up a right-sided
test instead of a left-sided test so
again we rejected the null hypothesis
which would be a correct thing to do
technically but we did it on totally
false pretences and then the tie for
error is an even less frequently used
term but still one that you might hear
floating around occasionally and that's
when you correctly reject the null
hypothesis but you make a mistake
interpreting the results at the end of
the day though the most important types
of errors are by far type 1 error and
type 2 error and it's important to
remember the common saying that there's
no such thing as a free lunch you
decrease your risk of making one type of
error you're going to increase your risk
of making the other type of error
statistics is a giant game of
probability and quantifying your
uncertainty and often times uncertainty
can come in multiple forms you've got
type 1 error you've got type 2
and by extension of type 2 error you
have power so these really are some of
the most important concepts in the
entire field so thanks for watching this
video if you enjoyed it and you'd like
to support my work the most helpful
thing that you could do for me would be
to share this video otherwise at least
consider smashing the like button and
then I'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then Richard on
data